school photograph yeah a good smile
Michael and Christine rouse all like to
remember their son Jason as a child they
fostered him as a baby and soon found
out he had a learning disability and
struggled to speak Jason was a kind
funny boy who loved being in the garden
but life change for Jason when wanting
to leave home and become more
independent his parents asked for help
from the local authority from the time
that he went into care we could see a
deterioration in him physically and
mentally if a vacancy comes up they seem
that they grabbed it irrespective of
whether it was suitable on arm
Jason was sent to seven different
institutions over the next 20 years
finally being sectioned in a secure
Hospital 150 miles from his family he
was supposed to be at Cedar House a
private hospital paid for by the NHS to
be quickly assessed and moved on he
stayed almost eight years until his
death in January 2018 Jason has stuck a
small bus and battery up his nose and
despite telling staff what he'd done it
took two days before he was taken for
emergency treatment he died because of
complications after surgery to remove it
the doctor responsible patients had
taken to hospital immediately when I
asked him why they didn't do what he
said is this normal and he said whatever
said no donnelly both Michael and
Christine say they tried to raise
concerns about Jason throughout his time
and care how he'd gained weight was
depressed and didn't need his medication
but they were ignored
I couldn't have screamed or shouted
louder and when you're talking to
so-called professionals you're talking
to Rick wall
you know best Hampshire County Council
which was in charge at Jason's Community
Care told us finding the right support
for a person with complex mental health
needs can be
challenging and they're working with the
NHS to improve the help available in
their area last year a Sky News
investigation found 40 people with a
learning disability or autism had died
while in secure hospitals between 2015
and 2018 we now know Jason was one of
them and since then we can reveal 10
further people have died in these
specialist units in the last year this
is a scandal that is continuing there is
abuse in these institutions and there's
a continuing overuse of physical
restraint over medication and seclusion
and the fact that there have been a
further 10 deaths and that no one is
owning up to the problem and saying we
are going to sort it is a shocking thing
for me the Department of Health and
Social Care told Sky News they're
determined to reduce the number of
people with autism or learning
disabilities in mental health hospitals
and have invested significantly in
community care while NHS England added
that in all cases appropriate processes
have been followed to ensure local
services make the necessary improvements
and in light of our report they've
arranged to meet Jason's parents the
hunter come group which runs the
hospital where Jason was held said since
mr. Thompson's tragic death we've taken
extensive steps based on our own
investigation efforts to mitigate the
risks posed by button batteries we
remain fully committed to improving our
practices but Jason's parents are
calling for action from the very top we
on the ground can only do so much what
we've got to do is highlight the
problems and if we don't highlight the
problems nothing is going to be done
anyway
face to face with the Health Minister
get answers from Jason's parents don't
just blame the hospital for his death
they say it was the entire care system
which let their son down at home with
his family Jason was happy and content
but he grew to become a man they barely
recognized Charlotte Lomas Sky News
and in response to that reporter the
Department of Health have released a
statement and it says this we are
determined to reduce the number of
people with autism or learning
disabilities in mental health hospitals
significant investments in community
support has already led to a 23%
reduction and we are determined to go
further it continues the NHS will reduce
inpatient numbers by thirty five percent
by next year and through the long term
plan we will reduce numbers even further
by investing in specialist services and
community crisis care and giving local
areas greater control of their budgets
to reduce avoidable admissions and
enable shorter lengths of stay